欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
很多人不知道怎么样去设置橱窗
也不知道如何把橱窗的价值充分的发挥出来
那么这一章节我们来讲一下橱窗的应用技巧
如何设置橱窗
让我们的店铺的整体的自然流量快速的拉升
把这些有价值的橱窗资源利用好
去实现我们的目标
那么接下来我们来看第一小节
我们要知道橱窗它对我们到底有什么样的作用
橱窗它其实就是一种营销推广的工具
在同等条件下它是享有优先排名的权益
也就是比如说你的产品同等的条件下
那么如果你的产品加了橱窗
而同行的产品没有加橱窗
那么你的产品可能就优先排名在
通行产品的前面, 那么后台是这样的, 这个板块应该大家都已经掌握了, 那么我们来讲一下关于橱窗的优势, 第一个就是我刚才说的, 他享有优先排名的权益, 在同等条件下, 比如说, 曝光, 点击, 访客, 询盘等, 同等条件的情况下, 橱窗产品, 排在非橱窗产品的前面, 你的产品如果绑定了橱窗, 那么可能就比
同行排名债更靠前
第二个就是
拥有公司网站首页推广专区
提升主打产品推广力度
也就是在产品业和
公司的旺步首页
都会有橱窗的
展示的一个板块
你都可以去设置
而且这些橱窗
你可以随时绑定各种
以核心的主推厂产品
让更多的买家看到
一个产品, 展示更多产品的款式, 第三个就是, 橱窗是可以自由更换的, 但是很多人他不知道怎么样去更换橱窗产品, 也不知道怎么样去优化橱窗产品, 所以说它的价值就没有在店铺里面充分的展示, 充分的得到应用, 到时候我们就要学会如何去选品, 如何去优化我们的橱窗, 那么橱窗的话,
我们可以展示的产品是优品, 实力优品, 爆品, 以这几种产品优先展示为主, 因为这几种产品都是有沉淀非常好的数据, 对于我们绑定橱窗来说, 它的贡献价值更大, 而且它的排名也更容易靠前, 所以在选品的时候肯定是优先考虑优品, 实力优品, 爆品, 这三种类型的产品, 那么这个就是关于橱窗的
我们已经理解了橱窗的原理和橱窗的作用之后
接下来我们就要去学习如何设置橱窗